[Music]
[Applause]
let's start with a bit of a
visualization exercise who comes to mind
when I say the word coder think of
someone who can whip up a quick computer
program or knows multiple different
programming languages do someone in mind
maybe okay Who pictured Mark Zuckerberg
quick show of hands anyone okay who
pictured some other Silicon Valley geeks
Nate oh me too who pictured Lindsay
Scott she's a top model a Victoria's
Secret Angel judge she's coated several
popular mobile apps who pictured ng
Collins gabbatha a 17 year old
Cameroonian boy who the self-taught
coder yet just won a huge international
coding competition run by Google
one more question why didn't you picture
yourself when it comes to coding we're
all played with self-doubt I'm not good
enough at math I can't get the syntax
right I'm Way too old to start coding
now these are exactly the myths
I'm here to dispel I'm confident you can
learn how to code and that your
professional life will be better for it
regardless of whether an executive
assistant senior executive or MBA
student you can make it through the ups
and downs and become a true coder for me
self-doubt with a familiar feeling in
the fall of 2015
enrolled in Stanford's intermediate
computer science class CS 107 the class
was over capacity
so we're met in an extra-large
auditorium in the business school semuc
the seats were filled with young
sophomores who waved their hands with
the professor pick me pick me as they
try to answer every single question this
is even more frightening because
computer science classes do not have
participation grades in the back of the
room there was me recovering investment
banker who felt ancient and out of place
in this crowd
among Stanford's brightest geniuses I
was really learning how to code for the
first time the first assignments in that
class nearly broke me it seems at 3:00
a.m. every night I'd be reading through
my code trying to find that one bug one
error that was preventing it from
running I read I searched
question whether I should just give up
throw in the towel and go back to my old
job making pretty stock price charts CS
107 that intermediate computer science
class and with a big assignment it's
called the heath allocator the heap both
stores and retrieves data the class
assignments evaluated both on accuracy
and time benchmarks I was convinced that
I was going to build the best heap that
I could I wanted to prove to myself I
belonged in that class so I set out over
Thanksgiving break to optimize my heap
keep coding keep trying and I couldn't
have been more pleased by the results if
I were to compare my heap to an Olympic
hurdler it not only would have been in
the final heap but it would have run a
bright shining medal it ran through the
assign task without making a single
mistake I couldn't have been prouder all
of those late nights were paying off I
was becoming a true coder a similar
victory is available to you you can make
it through the ups and downs and achieve
an incredibly worthy goal becoming a
coder I've talked to a lot of us with a
lot of my friends at Stanford about
learning how to code through those
conversations I've identified three
common questions the first common
question is what really is coding coding
is how humans boss computers are wrapped
we often talk about writing code but I
like to think about is collecting code
there's so many great programs online
today these can be combined together to
create something that's bigger than the
sum of its parts
what that means for you is that you can
get a lot of mileage out of the basic
understanding of coding you can stand on
the shoulders of giants and with a basic
understanding use the latest machine
learning algorithms or impress your
friends whatever else you want to make
up the second question often asked is
why is this important
technology has had the power to
continuously improve our lives yet our
skill set has needed to keep up to be
able to take advantage of those advances
for example think about typing like on a
typewriter in the 1950s only specialist
secretaries typed they sat in the middle
of office and processed everyone's
documents but time passed and in the
1980s personal computers became
prevalent then it was no longer
sufficient for just secretaries to type
everyone in the office needed to learn
how that's brought us today where typing
is an omnipresent skill
I expect we'll go through the same
trajectory with coding we're already
past the point where only engineers are
specialists in this case code out of the
top quartile jobs by ranked by salary
50% already requires some sort of coding
or technical skills so that means that
there are the marketers data scientists
these ops people those beyond engineers
who are already coding to me it's
inevitable that this trend continues
that we'll reach a point where all
people in all roles are coding you may
be thinking to yourself at this point
I'm going to be a manager I'll have my
engineers to do all the coding what a
good wishful thinking to be able to
effectively communicate with engineers
an understanding of code is critical it
helps you speak the same language and be
able to do your work faster and more
effectively
the third question I'm often asked is
how do I get started we are incredibly
fortunate Stanford to have incredible
coding resources available to us it's as
if we've stumbled into Sam Stanford
Sistine Chapel of computer science we
can look up and learn a ton from
Michelangelo stealing CS 106a one of the
most popular students one of the most
popular classes for MBA students
is being offered this spring of course
there are online resources too
one of my favorites is Cote Academy's
Python class in under 10 hours you can
go from knowing nothing about Python to
having a solid understanding of the
language and being able to build your
own programs you may be thinking at this
point when am I going to make time to
code I can barely do my laundry as is me
- ah
I completely understand we have so many
special opportunities available to us
here however if you're at all interested
in coding now is the best time to learn
we have access to unparalleled resources
at Stanford CS classes are pass/fail for
MBA students and they'll be more
distractions whether that's starting a
company or starting a family post
graduation picture yourself as a coder
humor me with one more visualization
exercise come on
so picture yourself it's a Wednesday
afternoon you're sipping on your
favorite caffeinated beverage you're in
the office and your laptop spoiling way
taking care of your chores updating
sales statistics scraping down customer
data and then there's you doing what
really matters you're mentoring a high
potential new employee or you're
thinking through your company's next
strategic moves you're doing the things
you came to Stanford GSB to learn how to
do what an incredible vision
don't let the opportunity to make this a
reality slip by with confidence in your
own abilities take a class and start
coding
[Music]